Film Courage: Let’s talk about the hypothetical
spec script, let’s suppose I want to get
on a show, what would be my method for doing
this?
Am I writing an episode that already exists?
A continuation of one?
Erik Bork, Author/Screenwriter: In television
these days to be in consideration for getting
your first writing job on staff of a show
which means you didn’t sell your own original
show, you got hired to write for someone else’s
show which is still the much more likely scenario
for a new writer, right?
People are writing original pilots and hoping
to sell them and get them on in front of an
audience of course there’s always a chance
that that could happen but it’s very rare.
Today people writing original pilots within
the industry, people who have managers and
agents writing original pilots, if they don’t
already have a big tract record writing for
television or film and a lot of success, they
are probably writing that as a writing sample
and trying to get a job on staff of a series,
what’s changed in the 20 years since I was
doing that is that back in the 90’s and
before, the traditional way to get hired on
staff of a series was to write what they would
call a spec episode of an existing show.
Just some successful relatively new show what
the industry liked and respected like SEINFELD
was the big show to do during its second season
is about the right time.
Where people are writing their own ideas for
an original SEINFELD that hopefully reads
like a really good episode of SEINFELD.
Like you read the script and you’re like
this could be on that show, it could be a
really good episode of that show, they capture
the voices, it’s very funny, etcetera, etcetera.
Not easy to do really well.
Easy to do mediocrely, not easy to do well
enough where people go “Wow!”
Which of course that’s what you want when
you’re a screenwriter is to get that wow
is rare and sight after, right?
So back then very few people wrote original
pilots if they weren’t already established
because there was nothing to do with them.
They weren’t looking for original pilots
as writing samples as much.
They want to know that you can write in another
writer’s voice an episode of show that already
existed which of course is what you would
be doing if you got hired on staff.
For some reason in the last 20 years that
has shifted a lot.
What I’ve heard anecdotally is that where
in those days 80 percent of it was specs of
existing shows and nowadays it’s like 80
percent of it is original pilots that people
are writing and that is what is getting the
managers and agents and getting their first
job on a series (on a writing staff).
People still do write specs of existing shows.
I think you definitely need to write them
to get into to some of the big fellowships
that some of the big studios and networks
offer which are great ways to try and break
into TV writing.
But what is much more in vogue is writers
writing original pilots for series that they
come up with and those pilots become their
main writing sample or samples that they use
to try to first get a manager and then get
an agent (they kind of have to go step-by-step)
and then having their managers sending them
to production companies, showrunners, executives
and the studios and networks, streaming services
to try to get you noticed as a potential TV
staff writer.
Film Courage: And so how long would these
spec scripts be?
So it’s going to be half-hour content?
Erik: Yes, it’s going to be the same typical
length for the script you’re writing for.
Well…if it’s original, a show of the ilk
of what you’re writing.
In other words, if you’re writing a one-hour
(clearly) a network style drama, it’s going
to be about 45-minutes because there are going
to be commercials and then how many pages
that translates to.
They say a minute a page, you can go a little
long.
In a spec I would say a 1-hour pilot, 60 pages
would probably be the max you’d want to
go for.
Whereas a pilot you’re really trying to
copy successful shows that are similar to
yours would do in terms of length.
So it’s really helpful to read scripts,
not just read episodes that inspire you to
want to write something in that genre whether
it’s an HBO-type show or a Netflix-type
show.
Nowadays those shows have services that can
have different length shows so that they’re
not a standard 20-minute half-hour comedy
on ABC there’s a little more flexibility.
So you don’t have to be too nervous about
the exact right number of pages but generally
you are emulating what is standard for the
kind of script that you’re writing.
Film Courage: Why do you say it’s so hard
to make a great spec script, it’s easier
to make a mediocre one.
What’s the cause?
Erik: Well, when you write an existing spec
script of a show, I think it’s easy-ish
to write something where the characters talk
the way the talk on the show and you have
the kind of jokes you can imagine they would
have but maybe they are not great jokes but
kind of okay jokes.
And the kind of story and behavior that is
their typical behavior.
It’s not so hard to mimic that.
It’s hard to mimic in a way that is as good
or better then an actual produced show is.
Because really for a way for one of those
script to stand out it actually has to be
better than the average episode.
It has to feel like “Why haven’t they
done this episode?
It’s like a great idea, it’s perfect for
the show, it’s really funny, it’s really
memorable.”
(If it’s a comedy obviously you are going
for the funny) and that’s just hard to do
really well.
It looks easy (which is why I tried to do
it), it looks easy to write a show that you
know is a good show to come up with your own
ideas for stories for an episode but to do
it on a level that someone would hire you
based on it is not easy and normally the show
you wrote it for is not going to hire you.
They’re probably not even going to want
to read it.
They probably will be tougher on it than any
other show will be because they know their
show so well.
And they probably aren’t looking for writers
because they are already on the air with a
hit.
So typically when you’re breaking into television
you’re breaking in with a staff writing
job on a brand new show that no one has ever
seen before.
You may not even love the show but it’s
where they offered you the job based on reading
your stuff and it may be a job that gets canceled
in its first season because most of them do
but that’s kind of the life of what they
call a baby writer (a writer breaking into
television working on staff).
But most of that doesn’t apply as much today
because most people are writing original pilots
instead of specs.
But obviously it’s hard to write an original
pilot that impresses people too.
Perhaps harder because now you’re coming
up with characters and a whole situation that
you know nothing about and you have to make
them care about these characters be entertained
and be intrigued and all that kind of stuff
and all of the problems of the show have to
be really compelling.
Whereas if you’re writing a spec episode
of an existing show, a lot of that has already
been done for you.
You just have to write a variation on something
that someone has already established.
Maybe that’s why nowadays those aren’t
valued as much because people can say “You
didn’t have to do as much to do that.”
On the other hand when you write on staff
of a show a big part of your job is mimicking
the voice of the showrunner.
Being able to execute the show in a way that
they would have liked, that they would have
done it, which is not a skill that every writer
has.
So to show you can write somebody else’s
show and their voice really I think is a valuable
thing.
But the industry is more interested in original
pilots for writing samples despite that I
think these days.
Film Courage: But you say it’s rare that…let’s
suppose for SEINFELD, I’m writing to get
on it and it’s still in existence, that
I’m writing this [for the show] and thinking
that I’m going to be in the writer’s room
for SEINFELD.
No…I’m submitting it for FRIENDS?
Erik: Well, you’re not submitting it for
FRIENDS, you’re submitting it for some show
that hasn’t even even on the air yet.
And that’s the reality because your agent
would be the one doing all the submitting,
right?
So first you have to impress an agent enough
to get an agent.
But once you have an agent, they are going
to be submitting these new potential writers,
all those brand new shows that just found
out they got a series order and now they have
to staff up.
The shows have are already on the air, they
already have a staff.
They may have one person leave and they fill
once vacancy but basically they are already
there.
So you’re almost never going to get on a
successful existing hit show that you love
or that you would have written a spec of.
You’re going to use that spec to get on
some brand new unknown show that you may or
may not love or may or may not be right for
but they thought you were right for based
on your script so there you go.